- Batman on Batman how did it look to
everybody people seem to be losing their
goddamn minds over the Kingsmen I'm
telling him and that first one snuck up
on me and it shouldn't have because I
liked all the players involved and also
behind the scenes as Mark Millar book
right here ton and Matthew Vaughn and
and I've been Matthew Vaughn insanely
talented but Mark Millar man like I love
I've loved him safe from the world of
comics I've loved him since he took over
Swamp Thing he did a run at Swamp Thing
back in the day that was really keyed
into the old alan moore run I was like I
like to cut of this guy's jib I like his
style so for years like I've kind of
watched his stuff and I remember like
he'd ask a lot any time I met him or
talked to him he's always asking about
movies and stuff his account cute for
this guy he likes movies good friend
this poor comic-book guy he'll never get
near a movie but good for him and [ __ ]
like that
cut to today like he has created his own
universe of films and they're viable you
know how tough it is just create a new
comic book that takes off let alone
takes off as a feature and they've been
able to do that with him and Matthew
Vaughn would kick ass and then with
Kingsman as well and that [ __ ]
sequence in the you know of the killing
in the church in the first movie yeah is
it as good as a cinematic sequence as
anything you'd see in Deadpool is
anything you would see and maybe even I
haven't seen you know Dunkirk but
anything [ __ ] knowns
it was a wonder it was fantastic it
reminds me of like old John Woo movies
like we are going to put a bunch of
people in an enclosed space and shoot
for a month and then we will deliver
unto you a thing you've never seen
before
yeah and the enclosed space isn't just
like four walls of green and then we're
gonna add a stark sky and a ring of
garbage later on like if they're
shooting an actual physical place in SF
which helps
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]